this is how he teach me this is how he  tried to teach me because he always tell  me  when you're gonna go to big arena you  can handle any any pressure but right  now you have to work hard  and I remember when I asked him when I  was young I was very young maybe like  six seven years old I remember it was  like a lesson for all my life I ask him  money  he said okay I'm gonna give you money  but you have to deserve this you think  I'm gonna give you everything what you  want no you have to deserve this  you know it's like it was very big  lesson like even like backstage I was  talking with DC I know he want his son  become world champion and he winning  like one like  gold around his neck I'm like this you  buy this for him  he's like yes I love him but this is not  about love  make him hungry  make him hungry